COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON DUE TO A BILL
GOING COVERT PRECAUTIONS. INTO
LITTLE HOUSEKEEPING. MASSA
REQUIRED FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS IN
THE HEARING IN THROUGHOUT
CAPITOL GROUNDS. YOU CAN
TESTIFY IN PERSON BY TELEPHONE
OR BY REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
OUTSIDE OF THE CAPITAL. THE
NUMBERS TO THE NUMBER TO CALL
IS. 877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS TWENTY FOUR. TO SIX TO
THIRTY SEVEN. THIS NUMBER CAN
BE FOUND ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE IS DISPLAYED ON YOUR
SCREENS. THOSE CALLING IN
PLEASE MAKE YOURSELF WELL IN
THE QUEUE TO ELIMINATE
BACKGROUND NOISE. REACH BILL
HEARD TODAY THERE WILL BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR TWO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO EACH PROVIDE TWO
MINUTES. OF TESTIMONY. FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES CALLING IN
YOU WILL BE PLACE IN THE QUEUE
UNTIL YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL BE ALTERNATED.
WHAT IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE COMMENT PRESS ONE. THEN
ZERO AND UNMUTE YOURSELVES TO
IN ORDER TO SPEAK. PLEASE BE
BRIEF LIMITING YOUR COMMENTS TO
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. WITH THAT. I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE A QUORUM NHà.
WE CAN SALAS. SO WHAT WITH THAT
WE WILL BEGIN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM THAT SURVEY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FRAZIER YEAH. BIGELOW
AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN. BRIAN
COOLEY COOPER DALY DAVIES
GALLAGHER EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON JONES SAWYER. LACKEY LOW.
MATHIS QUICKSILVER. RAMOS RIVAS
RUBIO. SALAS SMITH. WHERE FORM
FORUM WITHOUT AUTHOR SO I KNOW
THE SECTOR'S COOK OR THE-
SERGEANTS RECALLING. AUTHORS
OFFICES TO US HOPEFULLY THEY
CAN COME UP- WE REMEMBER
CONSENT CALENDAR HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT. SO THAT'S GREAT JOB ON
STAFFS. RULE SO- THE BY HURTING
GOOD JOKES LATELY. IT'S A BIG.
YEAH FOR THE AUDIENCE ON THAT
SO WE'RE GONNA CALL UP SB THREE
ONE FOUR- FOR MISTER WINNER
THERE WILL BE MISTER GABRIEL
PRESENTING- THREE ONE FOUR.
FORMICA. SO FORGERS. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TODAY TO PERCENT-
SENATE BILL THREE ONE FOUR ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR WIENER SB
THREE ONE FOUR WILL PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED RELIEF FOR
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL RESTAURANTS
AND BARS TO ENSURE THEY'RE ABLE
TO RECOVER ECONOMICALLY AFTER
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
EARLIER THIS YEAR THIS
COMMITTEE HEARD ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTY ONE WHICH TOGETHER WITH
SB THREE ONE FOUR WOULD CREATE
A NECESSARY LIFELINE FOR
RESTAURANTS AND BARS. THE
PANDEMIC HAS DEVASTATED SMALL
BUSINESSES PARTICULARLY IN THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY AT AN
ALARMING RATE SINCE THE FIRST
DAY HOME ORDER THIS INDUSTRY
HAS SUSTAINED. A BIG ECONOMIC
HIT AND CONTINUES TO STRUGGLE
TO REGAIN ALL THAT HAS BEEN
LOST. AS WE TRY TO REGAIN A
SENSE OF NORMALCY MANY OF OUR
LOCAL BUSINESSES WILL BE ONE
STEP AWAY FROM BANKRUPTCY AND
EASING ARBITRARY ABC
RESTRICTIONS WILL BE CRITICAL
TO THEIR SUCCESS AFTER THE
PANDEMIC AND BEYOND.
RESTAURANTS AND BARS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ARE IN DIRE NEED OF
FLEXIBILITY WITHINTHE A. B. C.
ACT AS MANY OF ANTIQUATED LAWS
INCLUDED IN IT MAKE IT MUCH
HARDER TO CONDUCT BUSINESS. SB
THREE ONE FOUR PROVIDES
FLEXIBILITY FOR RESTAURANTS AND
BARS IN FOUR WAYS. FIRST
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE A COVER
NINETEEN TEMPORARY EXPANSION
PERMIT. WILL BE ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE OPERATING FOR AT LEAST
ONE YEAR AFTER THE EMERGENCY
ORDER SELECTED. YOU CAN APPLY
FOR PERMANENT PROMISES
EXPANSION AT THE SAME TIME.
THIS EXPANDED OUTDOOR SEATING
AND SERVICE AREAS HAVE ALLOWED
RESTAURANTS AND BARS TO SURVIVE
AND HAVE BEEN WILDLY POPULAR
WITH THE PUBLIC. IF AFTER ONE
YEAR GRACE PERIOD BUSINESS HAS
SUBMITTED AN APPLICATION FOR
PERMANENT EXPANSION A. B. C.
CAN EXTEND THE GRACE PERIOD IF
THEY SO CHOOSE. SECOND THIS
BILL ALLOWS MANUFACTURERS THE
ABILITY TO SHARE A COMMON
LICENSE AREA WITH MULTIPLE
LICENSE RETAILERS SUCH AS BARS
RESTAURANTS OR OTHER
MANUFACTURERS. THIRD THE BILL
ALLOWS BUSINESSES TO USE A
CATERING LICENSE AT ONE
LOCATION THIRTY SIX TIMES
INCREASING THE ALLOWABLE LIMIT
FROM TWENTY FOUR. LASTLY
CURRENTLY AN EVENT MUST SUBMIT
THEIR PERMIT APPLICATION TO A.
B. C. MORE THAN THIRTY DAYS
BEFORE THE EVENT. THIS BILL
WILL INCREASE THE SPIRIT OF THE
TIME TO NINETY DAYS BEFORE AN
AND INSTEAD OF THE CURRENT
THIRTY DAY WINDOW. THESE
CHANGES WILL HELP US ADAPT AND
MOVE FORWARD FROM THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND ENSURE THAT IN THE
FUTURE THESE REGULATIONS ARE
MORE USER FRIENDLY FOR THESE
BUSINESSES. WITH ME HERE TODAY
TO TESTIFY AS LAURIE THOMAS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
GOLDEN GATE RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. AND BAD BLIND AND
CHAIR OF CALIFORNIA MUSIC AND
CULTURE ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
AN APPROPRIATE TIME WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. WILL MOVE ON
TO OUR FIRST WITNESSES SUPPORT
LAURIE THOMAS. MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE LAURIE THOMAS SIGNATURE.
MISTER I DON'T FEEL LAURIE TOP
LAURIE THOMAS OR BAND BY MEN ON
THE LINE. IF YOU'RE CURRENTLY
ON THE LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ZERO AND WILL OPEN UP YOUR LINE.
YES ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE ON
THE LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO TO OPEN UP YOUR LINE.
SUMMARY WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND MOVE FORWARD TO OTHER
WITNESSES- AND WE'LL COME BACK
TO JUST BEFORE WE- GO TO VOTE.
SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA ASK
ANYBODY IN THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TO COME
FORWARD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MATT SUTTON OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THERE'S TWO KEY PROVISIONS
BEFORE YOU WON THIS COMMITTEE
IS DEALT WITH BEFORE WHICH
RELATES TO. THE TEMPORARY
CATERING AUTHORIZATION THAT'S A
STREAMLINED PROCESS THAT ALLOWS
FOR SOME OF THESE REINVENTED
OUTDOOR DINING SPACES THAT YOU
SEEN THROUGHOUT YOUR DISTRICTS.
THE OTHER PIECE DEALS WITH SOME
FLEXIBILITY FOR CATERS TO SERVE
THE PUBLIC- WE ARE IN SUPPORT
AND ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. CAN SIX
MINUTES PLEASE MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON
BEHALF OF THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT FOR THE
REASONS THAT THE RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION ENUMERATED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS IN THE GALLERY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO. ANYBODY AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION OF.
WARNING THIS AS FINES FOR THE
BILL. COMING BACK UP NOW ANY
WITNESSES. IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. IN THE GALLERY. SEEING
NONE ANY WITNESSES AGAINST OR
OPPOSING THE BILL AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. USING NON
VERBAL FOR. WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE PHONES MODERATOR FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PLEASE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO PICK UP THE PART OF SB
THREE ONE FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE FIVE IN Q. OPEN
LINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
MEMBERS PROTESTED OFF ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORE ROOFTOP
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ONE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO SHARE NUMBERS IN MILLION
THE MONEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH HI YES THIS IS LAURIE
THOMAS- FROM THE GOLDEN GATE
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION NOW IT'S
BEST TO SPEAK AS A WITNESS SO
I'M GONNA GO NOW BECAUSE THEY
WANT ME IN BEFORE WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS AND
APPRECIATE THE HELP WE SERVE
HUNDREDS OF RESTAURANTS IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND CAFES AND THE
PAST FIFTEEN MONTHS- HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT FOR THE
RESTAURANT COMMUNITY AND THE
OUTDOOR SEATING AND THE ABILITY
TO SERVE ALCOHOL IN THE OUTDOOR
PARKWAY IT'S AN ON THE STREET
AND THEN THE FIVE OPTIONS AN
INCREDIBLY CRITICAL FOR OUR
SUCCESS. I KNOW MANY PEOPLE
THINK THINGS ARE RETURNING BUT
IN FACT WE JUST GOT WE ARE
SEEING DINER LEVELS DOWN 46%
FROM JUNE OF TWENTY NINETEEN
AND OVER ALL SMALL BUSINESS
REVENUE SPENDING IS STILL DOWN
FORTY EIGHT POINT 6% AND MANY
OF THOSE BUSINESSES ARE STILL
CLOSED IN AREAS LIKE OUR
DOWNTOWN AREAS WHERE IT'S SO
CRITICAL THAT WE GET PEOPLE TO
RETURN FOR CONVENTION CENTER
COME BACK TO WORK- YOU GUYS
KNOW THIS IS A CRITICAL
INDUSTRY WE PROVIDE OVER TWO
MILLION WORKERS JOBS WE
GENERATE OVER 12% OF CALIFORNIA
SALES TAX EXAMPLE JUST GO ALONE
WE EMPLOY MORE THAN SIXTY
THOUSAND FOOD SECTOR WORKERS.
AND WE DEFINITELY NEED A CHANCE
TO CLAW BACK OUT OF A HUGE
FINANCIAL LOSS WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ABC ANABOLIC
SENATOR WIENER'S WORK TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN AND WE ASK THAT YOU
STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT'S BUILT
TO MAKE US. A MORE PERMANENT
SITUATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THIS ONE MORE TIME FOR OUR
ADDITIONAL WITH THE SUPPORT.
HAVE BEEN- IF HE'S IN THE QUEUE.
OUR MODERATOR WOULD PLEASE LET
HIM THROUGH. WELL I MEAN IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO BEGIN OPEN YOUR
LINE. AND I HAVE NO ONE OFFICE
QUEUED UP. OKAY MURRAY LET'S GO
TO THOSE IN OPPOSITION OF THE
AUTHORS BILL PLEASE ON THE
PHONES. YOU CAN TELL ME IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE ONE FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO ZERO AFTER IT'S TIME.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MICHAEL SKIP ON BEHALF OF
ALCOHOL JUSTICE. OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE RECOVERING FROM
THE MOST OF YOURHEALTH CRISIS
OF OUR TIME EXPANSION OF
ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION SHOULD NOT
BE THE PRIORITY WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ADDITIONAL LINES ARE
CURRENTLY WITH OPERATORS ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE TO OPEN MY NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
MY THIRTY SEVEN. HI MEMBERS
FRED JONES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON ALCOHOL
PROBLEMS PRIMARILY A FAITH
BASED ORGANIZATION. CHAIRED BY
A BUNCH OF CURRENT OR RETIRED
PASTORS- WE SEE THE IMPACTS
THAT ALCOHOL CAN HAVE ON OUR
USE ON OUR COMMUNITY ON OUR-
CONGREGATIONS AND ALL OUR
BROADER STATE IT WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT. THE HODGE
PODGE OF PERMANENT CHANGES TO
THE ABC LAWS THAT S. B- THREE
ONE FOUR WOULD DO. WE
UNDERSTAND THEY WERE HARD HIT
DURING CALVET BUT- JUST TO FIND
PERMANENT CHANGES WE THINK ARE
IS NOT RESPONSIBLE. AND WE
STAND IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WHY FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MY
NAME AND I FIND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE AND THE LGBT PEOPLE
OKAY OF THE ALLIANCE AND WE'RE
CALLING IN OPPOSITION- SB THREE
FOURTEEN YOU'RE REALLY ARE
CONCERNED PERSONAL DISREGARD
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY TRAFFIC
SAFETY PEDESTRIAN SAFETY I'M
THE TYPE OF QUALITY OF LIFE
THAT WE ARE PROMOTING TO BE
BILLS AND- PARTY FOR THE
WALKABILITY OF A LOT OF OUR
CITY THAT ARE EXTREMELY
LACKING. THERE IS A DISREGARD
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AS IF WE
DIDN'T JUST COME OUT OF THE
MOST SEVERE PANDEMIC OF OUR
LIFETIME WE REALLY NEED TO
THINK CRITICALLY FOR SUPPORTING
BUSINESSES OVER PEOPLE AND
ENSURING SAFETY WE'RE TALKING
FAMILIES SENIORS CHILDREN IN
STROLLERS NOT HAVING ACCESS TO
WALKABLE CITIES THAT ALREADY
HAVE EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE
ISSUE. WE REALLY WANT TO
QUESTION THE COMMITTEE TO
REALLY THINK CRITICALLY ABOUT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PEOPLE OVER
PROFIT BECAUSE WE DO KNOW THAT
THE INDUSTRY IS HEAVILY
SUPPORTING THIS IS A VERY
BUSINESS CENTERED WE ARE NOT AT
FAULT WILL BENEFIT WHAT WE WANT
TO BE CRITICAL OF THE WAY THAT
THE BILL IS BEING PUSHED
FORWARD. I'M FROM A VERY
PRIVATE PROFIT I PERSPECTIVE-
PHILIP REALLY YOU THINK ABOUT
COMMUNITY ON. A SEPARATE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND AT TIME NO
ONE ELSE YOU FOR. THANK YOU
MODERATOR- ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE. THIS
BIGELOW THE SIMPLE ONE- I KNOW
YOU'RE REPRESENTING THE AUTHOR
BUT I'D LIKE TO BE LISTED AS A
CO AUTHOR. PASS THAT ALONG I
BET OTHERS MIGHT AS WELL.
PLEASE TAKE A ROLL OF- MEMBERS
OF LIKE THAT ON WITH THE MISTER
WINNERS BILL. WE TAKE NOTE OF
THAT PLEASE. OKAY WE'LL MAKE
SURE BEFORE YOU WALK OUT THE
CHECK IN WITH OUR- CHIEF
CONSULTANT MAKE SURE YOU WERE
ADDED TO YOUR SATISFACTION.
REALLY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. NONE THIS GABRIEL
WOULD LIKE CLOSE YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR I WILL
CERTAINLY CONVEY THOSE
ADDITIONAL CO AUTHOR REQUEST TO
AYE SENATOR WE ARE INSURE THAT
WILL BRIGHTEN HIS DAY- THIS IS
A AS AS YOU KNOW WE'VE ALIGNED
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
WITH AV SIXTY ONE MY BILL THESE
ARE BILLS ABOUT SUPPORTING OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES NEIGHBORHOOD
RESTAURANTS THAT ARE BARELY
HANGING ON BY A THREAD I KNOW
THAT THIS IS THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT TIME FOR THAT
REGULATORY RELIEF. BUT ALSO NOW
FOR THE RECORD IT HAS THE CO
AUTHORSHIP OF A CENTER MELENDEZ
AND SENATOR WIENER I'M NOT SURE
HOW OFTEN THE STARS ALIGNED BUT
THAT'S PROBABLY A GOOD SIGN
THAT THIS IS AN AND AN
EXCELLENT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AND WHAT THAT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR- SO WE DO
HAVE A FIRST IN THE SECOND ARE.
YOU WOULDN'T DAVIS FIRST AND
FIGURE KERR WAS SECOND- YOU
KNOW JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR IN YOU ALSO FOR YOUR
BILL- SUPPORTING BUSINESSES WHO
HAVE BEEN. THROUGH THIS
HORRIBLE PANDEMIC IN AND ARE
TRYING TO RECOVER- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE OBLIGATED
IS LEGISLATORS TO DO IS TO
REPRESENT- THE INTEREST OF ALL
BUT ALSO UNDERSTAND RECOVERY
BUSINESS IS PARAMOUNT TO THE
CALIFORNIA'S SUCCESS ALSO. AND
FOR THAT I THANK YOU- MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM ONE SB THREE
FOURTEEN BY SENATOR WIENER IF
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER HI FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW
HI BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN. BRIAN
BRIAN HI COOLEY COOLEY AYE
COOPER COOPER I DALY DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I'D GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA. GIPSON
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER.
BLACKIE LACKEY HELLO. MATHIS
MATHIS ICEBERG SILVA. RAMOS
RAMOS I RIVAS. RUBIO RUBIO AYE
SALAS CEMEX. SMITH ARE WE HAVE
FIFTEEN LEAVE IT OPEN. FIFTEEN
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR. SO WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO NUMBER TWO ON
OUR FILE SB THREE EIGHTY SIX
WAS DRUMMER CENTER PLEASE FROM
FOR JUST USE THE MIKE ON THE-
ON THE DESK PLEASE. NOON
CLOSURES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- I WANT TO THANK.
THE COMMITTEE STAFF IN
PARTICULAR OF ERIC JOHNSON CARL
MENDOZA FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL THAT ADDRESSES
AN ISSUE THAT WILL CREATE A
NUMBER OF JOBS AND
OPPORTUNITIES HERE IN OUR
DISTRICT IN CONNECTION WITH THE
HONDA CENTER AND X. EXPANSION-
WE WILL COMPETE I HOPE WITH LA
LIVE ONE DAY WITH THOSE C. BY
BUYER DRIVE OF. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO- WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. YES MR MATIX MANAGER
JOHN LATIMER. SO WE'LL MOVE
OVER TO MR MATT PICK FIRST.
THAT'S GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE FIRST ONE I THINK
CENTER NUMBER FOR CARRYING THE
BILL THEN I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR FOR HIS
RECOMMENDATION IN THE WORK OF
THE COMMITTEE STAFF. AS
MENTIONED THIS BILL SUPPORTS
THE DEVELOPMENT AND FINANCING
OF A NINETY FIVE ACRE MIXED USE
COMMUNITY AND LIVE
ENTERTAINMENT DISTRICT THAT
WILL SURROUND THE EXISTING
HONDA CENTER IN ANAHEIM. IT'S A
THREE BILLION DOLLAR PRIVATE
INVESTMENT WHICH WILL SPUR.
MORE THAN- TEN THOUSAND
CONSTRUCTION JOBS AND MORE THAN
THREE THOUSAND PERMANENT JOBS
UPON OPRATIONS. ALSO WILL
GENERATE SIGNIFICANT REVENUE
FOR THE CITY OF ANAHEIM THIS IS
A CITY LIKE MANY IN ORANGE
COUNTY THAT BEEN CRIPPLED BY
THE PANDEMIC. DUE TO ITS
RELIANCE ON TOURISM AND IT WILL
ALSO THE PROJECT WILL ALSO
PROVIDE A NUMBER OF PUBLIC
AMENITIES INCLUDING PARKS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. FOR THESE
REASONS I URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
VOTE YES AND I'M WILL BE ON
HAND TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE MR MEMBERS JOHN
LATIMER AGAIN ON BEHALF OF- C.
FIVE I WOULD SAY ECHO
EVERYTHING'S BEEN SAID ALREADY
AT ONE POINT I WOULD ADD. THIS
IS AN EXPANSION OF AN EXISTING
SPONSORSHIP EXEMPTION THAT THE
HONDA CENTER HAS ALREADY HAD SO
THEY'VE- IF YOU WILL
DEMONSTRATED ABILITY USE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY WISELY. I'M HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR
PERHAPS. IN THANK YOU SIR. ANY
MEMBERS IN THE GALLERY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO. VOICE OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SEEING
NONE. WE'RE GONNA TRY THE-
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO. TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. TO THE
AUTHORS BILL. HEARING NONE WILL
MOVE FORWARD TO THE- PHONES
MODERATOR WAS GO FOR FORD WITH
THE- WITNESSES SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL PLEASE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OF THE PORT OF SB THREE EIGHTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
ONE IN Q. ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES I'M ACTUALLY-
CALLING IN OPPOSITION. GO AHEAD.
IT'S MY CRITICAL WITH ALCOHOL
JUSTICE- WE BELIEVE THE
EXISTING- DEGRADATION OF TIED
HOUSE RESTRICTIONS WITH REGARD
TO THIS VENUE- WILL ONLY
EXPAND- TO THE COMMUNITY
SURROUNDING IT- WE ARE FIRMLY
OPPOSED TO IT AND DON'T BELIEVE
IT'S IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THOSE WHO WILL LIVE AND WORK IN
THE AREA THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MEXICO MODERATE. AND ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WOULD JUST BECAUSE THE
PART OF SB THREE EIGHT SIX YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT. OKAY MARIE
WALDRON LINES- TO ANY OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE AUTHORS BILL. CERTAINLY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE EIGHT SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO APPETITE. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE EIGHT
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. WE
HAVE NO ONE OPPOSED IN THE BILL.
IN SO CENTER REVIEW LIKE TO-
CLOSE I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I MAY HAVE
MISSPOKEN BEFORE WHEN I
MENTIONED ORANGE COUNTY THIS IS
REGIONAL THIS WILL BE A
REGIONAL ASSET THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK YOU
ANY- MEMBERS QUESTIONS. THAT OF
THE AUTHOR. MR DALY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AS A CO AUTHOR OF
THE BILL I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
IT AND- I DON'T KNOW IF A
MOTION WAS MADE. YET BUT TO.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MADE BUT ANYWAY
I'M A HIGH PRESSURE AT THE JOB
THE WORK. DONE BY CENTER-
BERGEN HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU MISTER DALY I KNOW
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT- INSURING
YOUR NEAR DISTRICTS ALSO- SO.
JUST APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD US SENATOR AGAIN
ANYTIME ANY ROLE THAT WE CAN.
CREATE OPPORTUNITY FOR
EMPLOYMENT IN CALIFORNIA IS-
SORELY NEEDED AND WE NEED TO BE
MORE CONDUCIVE TO THAT. AND
WITH THAT I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
TWO SB THREE EIGHTY SIX SENATOR
ON BIRD WITH THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. FRAZIER HI
FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. BERMAN BRANCH
BRIAN I COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
COOPER COOPER AYE DALY DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I GALLAGHER.
GARCIA GARCIA AYE GIPSON GIPSON
AYE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY LACKEY
I LOW MATHIS. KIRK SILVA. RAMOS
RAMOS I REQUEST. RUBIO RUBIO
AYE SALAS. SALAS I SMITH. SMITH
I HAVE FOURTEEN LEAVE IT OPEN.
BECAUSE FOURTEEN VOTERS BELIEVE
THE ROLE PERHAPS MEMBERS
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS. SO
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE NUMBER
OF FOLLOWERS NUMBER THREE SB
THREE EIGHTY NINE THE WORLD
FAMOUS ILLUSTRIOUS MISTER DODD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING ALL THE AMENDMENTS
LISTED IN AL-SISI'S. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFFER YOU WORK ON
THE BILL THIS BILL DOES TWO
THINGS THE FIRST IS TO CODIFY
LAST YEAR'S REGULATORY RELIEF
THAT ALLOWED RESTAURANTS. THE
ABILITY TO SELL BOTH PRE
PACKAGED ALCOHOL DRINKS IT
PREMIXED DRINKS TO CUSTOMERS AS
FAR AS THEIR- TO GO MEALS
ORDER. THE ABILITY TO CALL
ALCOHOLIC DRINKS IS BEEN A LIFE
WHY DO OUR RESTAURANT IN.
INDUSTRY DURING COVERT NINETEEN
THIS BILL SIMPLY EXTENDS THE
AUTHORITY FOR FIVE YEARS IN
GIVES RESTAURANTS THE OPTION TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE. FIVE
ALCOHOL DRINKS AS PART OF THEIR
MAIL ORDER. IN ADDITION THE
BILL REQUIRES THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY COMPANIES WHO ARE
DELIVERING ALCOHOL BE HAPPY
I'LL CALL LICENSEE. TO OBTAIN A
PERMIT FOR THE DEPARTMENT ABC.
I WANT TO POINT OUT- TO BE VERY
CLEAR THAT THIS DOES NOT
LEGALIZE OF DELIVERY OF
ALCOHOL. BY THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY COMPANIES. THAT
CLEARLY IS ALREADY TAKING PLACE
IT WILL CONTINUE TO OCCUR
REGARDLESS OF THIS BILL. WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS PROVIDE TO
COMMONSENSE APPROACH TO GIVE
THE DEPARTMENT OF ABC. THE
NECESSARY OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE
THE DELIVERIES ARE BEING DONE
IN A RESPONSIBLE MANNER THE
PROTECTS AGAINST UNDERAGE
DRINKING IN OVER INTOXICATION.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL REQUIRES
DELIVERY DRIVERS WHO ARE
DELIVERING ALCOHOL TO COMPLETED
TRAINING IT AUTHORIZES ABC TO
IMPOSE FINES ON THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY COMPANIES. NOT
DELIVERY DRIVERS I DON'T THINK
SO AND WITH THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN TODAY. THIS BILL MAKES A
VERY CLEAR THE DEPARTMENT BBC
CAN SUSPEND OR REVOKE A
CONSUMER DELIVERY SERVICE
PERMIT. WHEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES
WARRANT SUCH DISCIPLINE I'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
THIS COMMITTEE STAKEHOLDERS.
AND THE DEPARTMENT ABC TO
ENSURE THAT THIS BILL IS BOTH
WORKABLE AND ENFORCEABLE WITH
ME. IT JOHN LATIMER ON BEHALF
OF SEVEN ELEVEN IN THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. MISTER SUTTON
MISTER SAID WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND START YOUR TESTIMONY AND-
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATT SUTTON OF
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATION I THINK SENATOR
DODD EXPLAINED IT WELL THIS IS
ACTUALLY ADDING PROTECTIONS TO
EXISTING LAW WELL MAKING A
SLIGHT EXPANSION OF WHAT CAN BE
DELIVERED AND I WOULD JUST
POINT OUT THAT RESTAURANTS. MAY
BE ALLOWED TO REOPEN FULLY
SINCE JUNE FIFTEENTH THAT WE
ARE NOWHERE NEAR FULLY RE OPEN
AND CONSUMER DEMANDS AND
DESIRES HAVE CHANGED AND A BILL
LIKE THIS ALLOWS US TO CONTINUE
TO FULFILL THOSE DESIRES OF
CONSUMERS AND COMMUNITIES IN A
SAFE WAY AND SO WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THE Q. NEXT WITNESS
THE SLAMMER. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JOHN LATIMER ON BEHALF
OF THE RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
SEVEN ELEVEN AND I WOULD BUILD
UPON- FOR MR SUTTON SAID
SPEAKING JUST TO THE DELIVERY
PORTION OF THE BILL FOR A
MOMENT. AGAIN I THINK THE
AUTHOR EXPLAINED IT WELL THIS
IS CURRENTLY LEGAL HOWEVER. IT
IS NOT JUST SIMPLY HOW DO WE
KEEP THIS GOING IN A POST
PANDEMIC ENVIRONMENT THE USE OF
DELIVERY SERVICES BY CONSUMERS
HAS BEEN RISING YEAR AFTER YEAR
BECAUSE IT'S AN IMPORTANT
VALUABLE. BENEFIT TO THEM. ONE
OF MY CLIENTS SEVEN ELEVEN
STORES ALONE DID OVER HALF A
MILLION TRANSACTIONS LAST YEAR.
BEGIN PRE COVERED THROUGH
COVERT OVER HALF MILLION
TRANSACTIONS THAN DID INVOLVE
THE SALE OF ALCOHOL.THAT'S
LEGAL AND PERMISSIBLE TODAY
HOWEVER WHEN THERE IS A BREAK
DOWN IN THE DELIVERY WHEN
THERE'S A MISTAKE MADE ANY
MINOR IS GIVEN ACCESS TO THAT
PRODUCT THE ABC HAS NO. MEANS
REGULATORY LEAD TO ATTACH ANY
RESPONSIBILITY TO A DELIVERY
COMPANY INSTEAD THEY COME BACK
TO YOUR RETAILER YOUR
RESTAURANT IN YOUR DISTRICT. WE
WANT TO WORK WITH THE DELIVERY
COMPANIES THEY'RE REALLY
IMPORTANT PARTNERS AGAIN
THEY'RE VALUABLE TO OUR TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS OUR CUSTOMERS IN
YOUR CONSTITUENTS HOWEVER. WE
HAVE TO ESTABLISH A REGULATORY
MODEL FOR THEM WHERE BY THE
DEPARTMENT AN ENFORCE AGAINST
THEM IF IT'S NECESSARY. THAT
DOESN'T HURT THE DELIVERY
COMPANIES IT DOESN'T HURT THE
DRIVERS FRANKLY IT MAKE SURE
THAT THE PENALTY GOES TO THE
DELIVERY COMPANY. SO WE THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP THAT
HELPS KEEP THIS GREAT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN RETAIL
RESTAURANT AND DELIVERY
COMPANIES GOING. LEADER DRIVE
UP. THANK YOU. SO WE'RE GONNA
GO INTO THE GALLERIA IF ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. IN
THE GALLERY. SEEING NONE WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO- THE PHONES
THERE IS A ONE WITNESS- LISTED
IN OPPOSITION- SHANE GOODMAN
FROM THE COOPERATIVE TEAMSTERS
AND- MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE FOR MISTER
GOODMAN. LEVINE IS OPEN. MR
HEARING MEMBERS MAC BRIDE IN
NEWER SHANE GOT TO MEN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS WE'RE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED SB THREE
EIGHTY NINE WELL WE RECOGNIZE
THE CRITICAL ROLE I'LL CALL THE
GUY WAS PLAYING FIFTEEN
RESTAURANTS DURING THE PANDEMIC
ANY EFFORT TO EXTEND ALCOHOL
DELIVERY MUST DO SO WITH THE
SAFETY OF WORKERS AND CONSUMERS
AND MINE. HAS DRAFTED SB THREE
EIGHTY NINE WOULD CREATE A
CONSUMER DELIVERY SERVICE
PERMITS FOR THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY PLATFORMS NEGATIVELY
THIS CHANGE WILL SHIFT
LIABILITY FROM RESTAURANT THE
VULNERABLE DELIVERY DRIVERS
MANY OF WHOM ARE CLASSIFIED AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS WE
APPRECIATED CENTER DOTTED THE
KNOWLEDGE THEY NEED TO IMPROVE
THE STATUS QUO OR ALCOHOL
DELIVERIES ARE TAKING PLACE
RIGHT NOW WITHOUT ANY OVERSIGHT
THAT'S REFLECTING THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THE STEP THAT
PENALTY STRUCTURE. WITHOUT MORE
OVERSIGHT FOR THE ABC AS WELL
THAT SAID IT IS UNCLEAR- WHO
THE PENALTY ACTUALLY FALLS ON
OUR READING IS THAT BECAUSE THE
CLASSIFICATION THE DRIVERS AND
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS THE
PENALTIES COULD BE PUSHED OFF
OF THE LICENSE CONSUMER
DELIVERY SERVICE ARTIST'S WORK
FORCE AS WE KNOW THESE DRIVERS
ACTED HARMONY IN THE DISCRETION
TO DETERMINE WHO RECEIVE
ALCOHOL OR TO REFUSE TO EVERY.
THAT IS WELL REFLECTED IN THE
ABC'S APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
VI<c.cyan> THREE IN WHICH THE</c>
DEPARTMENT CONCLUDED THAT
DELIVERY APPS LOG I'M MUCH
WORSE RATED SELLING ALCOHOL TO
MINORS IN FACT IN FOUR OUT OF
FIVE INSTANCES A MINOR COULD BE
EXACTLY ORDER AN ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE THROUGH DELIVERY AFTER
IT AFTER A COMPANY THEIR
LICENSE UNDER STATUTE THE NEED
TO SHARE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
PENALTIES RESULTING FROM DRIVER
MISCONDUCT WHICH WOULD SIMPLY
CREATE PARITY WITH BRICK AND
MORTAR LICENSEES WHERE THE
FAILURE RATE AND SELLING TO
MINORS IS SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER-
UNDER EXISTING LAW WHEN HE
DIRECTED PLAYED A LICENSEE
FURNISHES ALCOHOL TO MINORS THE
LIABILITY FALLS THE PERMIT
HOLDER. BE A VICARIOUS
LIABILITY WE SEE NO REASON NOT
TO MERE THAT. EXISTING
STRUCTURE BY ADDING QUITE- FIND
LANGUAGES THE BILL WILL GO LONG
WAY TOWARD THE YOU ACTUALLY
FALL. ALTERNATIVELY COMMAND THE
TRACK TO LIVE OUT CALL COST TO.
THE EMPLOYEES I THE CONSUMER
DELIVERY. YOUR CALIFORNIA
KENNETH DRY ARE TO BE DIRECTING
OF THE- DISPENSARY FOR LARGELY
THE SAME RE. EITHER WAY WE
WOULD INSIST HE BILL CREATES A
MORE ROBUST LICENSING STRUCTURE
SO THAT COMPANIES LICENSES
CONSUMER DELIVERY SERVICES IN
THE STATE ACTUALLY CARRY
LIABILITY. AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
DOCTOR ON POTENTIAL FIXES. I TO
THE BILL THAT WOULD RESOLVE OUR
CONCERNS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER.
PERSONALIST I GUESS NOT FOR
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE FORWARD IS TO
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
MEMBERS FOR. WORLD FOR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OPPOSITION OF THE
AUTHORS BILL. IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE. MARIA WE'RE GONNA
MOVE OVER TO SUPPORT- FOR THE
AUTHORS BILL PLEASE SUPPORT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE EIGHT NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE THREE IN Q. ONE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MORE TALK ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS JACKIE
GRAY WALLICH YES YOU W. WESTERN
STATE COUNCIL AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE FELLOW LINE
ARE COMMON BUT THAT IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KEVIN MCCUE ON BEHALF OF
THE DISTILLED SPIRITS COUNCIL
WE SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
ONE FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHRIS WALKER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. AND BEFORE WE
OPEN LINE THIRTY ONE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WOULD JUST BECAUSE THE PART OF
SB THREE EIGHT NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. ONE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LAPTOP AND-
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
NOT THE HIGHEST YOUNG BEHALF OF
THE FAMILY WINEMAKERS THE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE ONE MORE Q. BUT
THEY'RE CURRENTLY WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
WHEN I OPEN MY NUMBER FIFTY ONE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JACQUELINE
VERA NOT MANY OPPOSITION. I'LL
BURN A COLLISION THAT BUTTON.
ON UNDERAGE. ALCOHOL AND
MARIJUANA PREVENTION IN THE
EAST BAY. I FEEL LIKE THIS BILL
WILL HAVE NEGATIVE EFFECTS ON
THE COMMUNITY. AND AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE ON BOARD.
THANK YOU MARIE WILL MOVE OVER
TO- MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON
THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
AUTHORS BILL. PLEASE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
SB THREE EIGHT NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ZERO AT THIS TIME.
LINE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SORRY I FOLLOWED
THE CHAIRMAN'S ADVICE TO PUT MY
PHONE ON MUTE THIS IS FRED
JONES OF CALVARY HELPFUL NOW
CALL PROBLEMS AGAIN- I'M FOCUS
JUST ON COCKTAILS TO GO THE
REASON WHY IT'S CURRENTLY LEGAL
IS BECAUSE IT'S EVERYONE'S
OPERATING UNDER EMERGENCY ABC
REGULATIONS THIS BILL WILL MAKE
IT STATUTORILY PERMANENT. ABC
CAN PROVIDE CRIMINAL REFERRALS
ON THESE THIRD PARTY DELIVERIES
COMPANIES RIGHT NOW BUT WE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE EFFORT TO
TRY TO GET ABC MORE
ADMINISTRATIVE AUTHORITY OVER
THE WHOLE ENCHILADA AND
SPEAKING OF ENCHILADAS WE WOULD
PREFERRED THIS BILL. BE LIMITED
TO ONLY FOOD ORDERS SO
COCKTAILS TO GO THAT ARE PART
OF THE MEAL. AS OPPOSED TO
CREATING A MARKET INCENTIVE
THEY HAVE BARS ON THE GO. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- YEP
GO- FRED'S COMMENTS AND ALSO
WANT TO STATE THAT THERE ARE
ALREADY NUMEROUS METHODS FOR
CONSUMERS TO ACQUIRE ALCOHOL IN
PERSON. AT RETAIL OUTLETS ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT DO NOT NEED
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
PURCHASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MY NINETY
MINUTES I AM A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE AND THE LGBT PEOPLE
COCKETT HIRING IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THREE EIGHTY NINE WE HAVE
GRAVE CONCERNS BY THE WAY
BACKUP HELP TO GO WILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT THE
LGBTQ PLUS. COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND LOW INCOME FOLKS- WE
DON'T HAVE ANY MEASURES TO
ENSURE THAT FOLKS THAT ARE
ALREADY TARGETED FOR DRUNK
DRIVING AND POLICING IN
COMMUNITIES- WELL BEING YOU
PROTECT THEIR- DO HAVE ANY MAY.
SAID STATE WITHIN THE BELTWAY.
THAT THE ADEQUATE ENFORCEMENT
IT'S GOING TO BE DONE IN A WAY
THAT IS EQUITABLE AND JUST FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- IN AN
EQUITABLE WAY. ALREADY WANT TO
AND QUESTION- THAN THEM THE
COMMITTEE TO REALLY THINK ABOUT
THE WAYS IN WHICH THE CELL WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT.
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE MULTIBYTE
WILL BE DISPROPORTIONATELY AND
WE WANT TO REALLY ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO REALLY THINK ABOUT
HOW WE'RE ENABLING A QUALITY OF
LIFE THAT DOES NOT PROTECT FROM
COLD LEAD WE HAVE NOT. OVERCOME
COLD YET AND WE REALLY NEED TO
THINK ABOUT THE ACCESS TO
ALCOHOL AND HOW WE REALLY DON'T
HAVE ANY WAY TO AFFECT THE ARE
WHO. WE ARE CONSIDERED BE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND ANY
FUNDING TO REALLY ADDRESS THE
EXISTING HARM THAN THOSE THAT
WILL COME. AFTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER. SB
YOU OPEN ONE OF FIFTY OF THEM
WE JOHN IF YOU WISH TO UP A OF
AT THREE NINETY MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO ONE FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAITLIN VEGA
ON BEHALF OF THE- LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FEDERATION OF LABOR. AND
UNITE HERE LOCAL ELEVEN. ALSO
IN AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
FOR THE REASONS STATED BY THE
TEAMSTERS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
SUPPORTING THE BILL NO OTHER
CALLERS THANK YOU MODERATOR.
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO- WELL
LET'S GO TO THE CASE FIRST FOR
A QUESTIONS OF THE OF THE
AUTHOR ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR. THE COMMITTEE. THREE
MOST. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND NOT TO THE
AUTHOR- YOU KNOW WITH THEM THE
DIFFERENT TESTIMONY FROM THE
TEAMSTERS AND YOU HAVE C. W.
KNOWING THAT THIS IS COME ON
NOW JUST WANTED TO- SEE OF
THERE'S- AREAS THAT YOU CAN
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE WITH THEM
AS THIS BILL CONTINUES TO MOVE
FORWARD. I YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BY ALL MEANS I'M ALWAYS WILLING
TO WORK WITH ANYBODY THAT.
WANTS TO COME. IN AND TALK
ABOUT ANY BILL. IN THIS BILL IN
PARTICULAR I'D CERTAINLY LIKE
TO TALK TO HIM BECAUSE- YOU
KNOW THE CERTAINLY- THE POINT
OF THEIR TESTIMONY TODAY JUST
DON'T RESONATE. AND DON'T MAKE
A LOT OF SENSE IN TERMS OF IN
OUR FRANKLY INACCURATE SO LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING TOGETHER
WITH THEM AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT-
SENATOR AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
SOME MEANINGFUL DIALOGUE OUT OF
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEVEN
MEMBER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE AUTHOR FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU SENATOR HI SIR
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR OUR
CONVERSATIONS ON THE BILL
MOVING FORWARD AND THEN THE
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH TO HAVING A
SENSE OF MAKING SURE THAT
THESE- THESE OPPORTUNITIES
PRESENT THEMSELVES IN ANOTHER
WAY TO LOOK AT IT SEE IF THEY
ARE ARE WORKING LATER ON THEY
APPRECIATE YOU- VETTING THAT IN-MAKING THAT HAPPEN- WITH THAT.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND FILE ITEM THREE SB THREE
EIGHTY NINE SENATOR DODD THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. FRAZIER HI
FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE BERMAN BERMAN I BRIAN.
BRIAN I COOLEY COOLEY AYE
COOPER COOPER AYE DALY DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I GALLAGHER.
GARCIA GARCIA AYE GIPSON. JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY
ON LACKEY I LOW. MATHIS MATHIS
AYE PERKS SILVA. RAMOS RAMOS I
REQUEST. RIVAS AYE RUBIO. RUBIO
AYE SALAS SALAS I SMITH. SMITH
I WE HAVE SIXTEEN LEAVE IT OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
WHO. OKAY THANK YOU MISTER GOD
WILL GET THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. FEDERAL WAY SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO NUMBER
FOUR SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE
WELCOME AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE A BILL THAT
WOULD DESIGNATE. AUGUST TWENTY
SIX IS CALIFORNIA FORMER PER
DAY. ONE OF THE CONTRIBUTIONS
FARMWORKERS PROVIDE TO THE
STATE. AS AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA IS NUMBER ONE IN OUR
CULTURE AND- THAT- DEPENDS ON
SKILLED LABOR TO. SUSTAIN A
FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY
THE STATE PRODUCES OVER FOUR
HUNDRED DIFFERENT COMMODITIES
INCLUDING TWO THIRDS OF ALL
FRUITS AND NUTS IN THE UNITED
STATES MORE THAN ONE THIRD OF
ALL THE VEGETABLES IN THE
UNITED STATES CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO SOME. EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND FARMWORKERS 75% OF
THESE ARE UNDOCUMENTED. SB
SEVEN TWENTY ONE WOULD
ESTABLISH AUGUST TWENTY SIX IS
CALIFORNIA FAR FROM WORKING
DAY. SO THAT WE COULD CELEBRATE.
AND ALSO REFLECT ON ALL THE
THING THE SUFFERERS DUE TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY NUMBER ONE NATION AN
ATTIC POWERHOUSE IN THE WORLD.
I HAVE A FEW ALLOW MISTER
CHAIRMAN MARC ALI SADA GOT HIS-
REPRESENTING LOCAL COMPETITIVE
A COMPASS ENOUGH THE CALIFORNIA
THAT WOULD LIKE TO ADD
STATEMENTS. SIR PLEASE- NEAR
MAYES PERCY OKAY- OF COURSE I'M
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE TO
DESIGNATE AUGUST TWENTY SIX AS
CALIFORNIA FARMWORKER DURING.
IN CALIFORNIA SURGIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THE FARMWORKERS EMERGES
ARE ONE EIGHT THE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR THE FARMS GROWTH
WHERE DEGREE WHERE LABOR HAD TO
BE HIRED. HIGHER LABOR STARTS
TO CARRY OUT THE CULTIVATION
AND HARVESTING UP THE
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION IN THE
STATE THE FARMER BECOMES THE
INDISPENSABLE NECESSITY FOR THE
GROWTH OF THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE BEGINNING OF
THE LABOR FORCE INCLUDED
CHINESE AND JAPANESE EVENTUALLY
A LARGE SCALE FARMERS SEEKING.
HIGHER MEXICAN FILIPINO WORKERS.
THE JUSTICES SUFFER GRADUALLY
BECAME KNOWN OUTSIDE THE FARMS.
AND THE FIRST EFFORTS TO
ORGANIZE. ENDING IN BLOODY
CONFRONTATIONS CAME JUST BEFORE
WORLD WAR ONE. THE REVOLUTION
IN MEXICO IN NINETEEN TEN COST
THOUSANDS OF MEXICANS TO FREE
TO THE UNITED STATES. THE
SUPPLIER FARMWORKERS INCREASE
AND IN FACT BY NINETEEN TWENTY
IN CALIFORNIA THE FARMWORKER
LABOR FORCE HAS GROWN TO OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND. THIS
LABOR FORCE IN LARGE PART
HEALTH THE WORLD WAR ONE EFFORT
BY CONTINUING TO ASSIST IN THE
PRODUCTION OF THE FOOD NEEDED
DURING THIS PERIOD. NOW THE
LAST. IT WAS A LABOR FORCE THAT
WAS XCLUDED FROM THE NATIONAL
LABOR ACT OF NINETEEN THIRTY
FIVE AND CONTINUE TO ALLOW MANY
INEQUITIES THERE WERE NOT
ALLOWED FOR THE REST OF THE
LABOR FORCE IN THE COUNTRY. AND
IS WORLD WAR TWO APPROACH
WHAT'S MORE THE FARMWORKER
COMING FROM MEXICO THROUGH THE
BRACERO PROGRAM SUPPLIED THE
DESPERATELY NEEDED LABOR FORCE
FOR THIS COUNTRY. AFTER THIS
PROGRAM MANDATE THE LABOR FORCE
CONTINUE TO BE MAINTAINED BY
THE INFLUX OF LARGE NUMBERS OF
UNDOCUMENTED FARMWORKERS FROM
MEXICO. THIS SUMMER THE FARM
WORKER WAS A KEY FACTOR TO THE
INITIAL GROWTH OF THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY OF
CALIFORNIA THE FARM WORKER HELP
MAINTAIN THE PRODUCTION OF FOOD
DURING THE TWO WORLD WARS THE
PHARMACY IS WORKING IN THE
FIELDS PROVIDING FOOD ONE
EXPOSED TO THE TOXIC SMOKE OF
THE WILDFIRES WITHOUT ADEQUATE
PROTECTION A FARM WORKER WAS
PRODUCING FOOD FOR US DURING
THE CORONA VIRUS FOR ENDEMIC
RISKING INFECTION WHILE DOING
THAT. THEY WERE NOT AN
ESSENTIAL WORKFORCE THEY BECAME
A SACRIFICIAL WORK FORCE WHAT
THE CONDITIONS UNDER WHICH THE
FARMWORKER WORKS HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED THEY HAVE NEVER
FAILED TO PRODUCE THE FOOD
NEEDED IN THE STATE AND FOR THE
NATION THE OVER FIFTY BILLION
DOLLAR AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA IS THE ENVY OF THE
WORLD AND HAS AN ESTIMATED
EIGHT HUNDRED FARMWORKERS DOING
THE WORK AND THEY ARE TRULY ON
RECOGNIZED. BY THE WAY IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT OVER 50% OF
THESE WORKERS ARE UNDOCUMENTED
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE FOR AS THESE TWO SEVENTY
ONE TO GIVE THE DESERVE
RECOGNITION FOR THE FARM WORKER
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY. OTHER
MEMBERS IN THE GALLERY THE LIKE
TO. TESTIFYING SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL. SEEING NONE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC A LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION IN THE
GALLERY TO THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE. WE'RE GONNA GO TO
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THE AUTHORS BILL.
THING NINE. WE'RE GOING TO
PHONES MODERATOR OF. COLORS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL PLEASE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO BECAUSE SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN TWO ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN TWO ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE IN SUPPORT OF THE PHONE
LINE. SO LET'S MOVE OVER TO THE-
OPPOSITION TO THE PAST- SEVEN
TWENTY ONE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
IN LINE FOR THAT PLACE. HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE YES- LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
TWENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN TWO ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE OPPOSED THE BILL ON
THE PHONE LINE. THANK YOU
MODERATOR DONE WONDERFUL JOB
TODAY- ANY QUESTIONS OF THE-
COMMITTEE MR BIGELOW. THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR HEY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR DOING THIS AND
CHAMPIONING THIS I'D LIKE TO BE
A CO AUTHOR ON THIS WITH YOU.
ANY OTHER. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
THIS IS YOUR KERR. THANK YOU.
THIS IS WHERE THIS MATHIS ROLE
OKAY DO ROLL CALL YOUR HANDS
PLEASE SO WE CAN SEE THAT- WHO
WANTS TO BE ADDED ON AS CO
AUTHORS. AND IF NOT ALREADY.
ONE OKAY IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
UNANIMOUS MAYBE MR RAMOS
DOESN'T WANT TO. OKAY DOES. I
DIDN'T HEAR HIM THANK YOU I
THINK EVERYBODY ARMS. MISTER
HUESO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SIMPLY AS I APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S SUPPORT AND YOUR
REQUEST TO BE ADDED THIS CALL
AUTHORS APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH AND I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
IN I JUST HAVE TO GO BACK TO
YOUR WITNESSES COMMENTS. WHO
WERE. SPOT ON ABOUT SOME OF
THE- THINGS THAT THE- INDUSTRY
GOES THROUGH BUT- THERE ARE
THERE'S A CONSISTENCY THERE
WITH. THESE THESE THESE FOLKS
WHO ARE THERE EVERY DAY. IN IN
SMOKE RAVAGED- CALIFORNIA EVERY
DAY IN THE HEAT- THEY'RE DOING.
WORK FOR US THAT IS UNDER
APPRECIATED I WANT YOU TO KNOW
HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE YOU AS A
PERSON WORKS THIS HANDLES LIFE
ALSO NOT AS FAR AS THEY DO. BUT
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE- IT'S A
IT'S TIME TO- RECOGNIZING-
THAT'LL BE SUPPORTING ASKING
VEHICLE OFFERINGS OF. HI MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND FILE ITEM FOR SB SEVEN
TWO ONE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE FLOOR. FRAZIER HI
FRAZIER BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BERMAN. BERMAN I BRIAN. BRIAN
HI COOLEY COOPER COOPER I DALY.
DALY AYE DAVIES. DAVIES I
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA AYE GIPSON. JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
I LOW. LOW AYE MATHIS. MATHIS I
PERK SILVA. RAMOS DRAMAS I
RIVAS. RIVAS AYE RUBIO. RUBIO
AYE SALAS SALAS I SMITH. SMITH
FIVE TWELVE NINETEEN LEAVE IT
OPEN. THANK YOU MEMBERS. THANK
YOU SENATOR SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO- LIFTING THE CALL-
IF YOU HADN'T. YOU HAVE BEEN
HERE- THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
THANK YOU AND HAVEN'T HERE'S
YOUR CHANCE TO OUT ON. THE GOOD
DAY. SUMMARY RIGHT. FILE ITEM
ONE SB THREE FOURTEEN BERMAN.
BERMAN I. GALLAGHER GALLAGHER
WAS AN AYE GARCIA. GARCIA I.
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER I LOW.
LOW I KIRK SILVA. ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I SAW LAST. SALAS
EYES TWENTY ONE. FILE ITEM TO
SB THREE EIGHTY SIX
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY I
BERMAN BERMAN I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I GIPSON. JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER I LOW. LOW
II CREEK SILVA. RIVAS. THE
RIVAS HI OKAY I HAVE. TWENTY
FILE ITEM THREE SB THREE EIGHTY
NINE GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I
GIPSON. LOW LOW AYE PERK SILVA.
THIS EIGHTEEN. SB SEVEN TWO ONE.
COOLEY GIPSON. CORK SILVA. OKAY
IS.
NINETEEN SO WE WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR A FEW MORE
MINUTES OF THOSE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM ONE SB THREE FOURTEEN
CORK SILVA. YEAH YOUR. CREEK
SILVA I FILE ITEM TWO SB THREE
EIGHT SIX CORK SILVA. CORRECT
SILVA I. FILE ITEM THREE SB
THREE EIGHT NINE CORK SILVA.
FILE ITEM FOR SB SEVEN TWO ONE
CORK SILVA. WORKS OF ART BY. D.
OKAY. MISTER SMITH SPEAKING ON
THE INTERNET AFTER THAT AND
THAT'S FOR A BROKEN. WE COULD
SEE IT WILL BE WE- ANYTHING-
THIS.
FILE ITEM THREE SB THREE
EIGHT NINE. SENATOR DODD THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS GIPSON.
GIPSON I. NINETEEN FILE ITEM
FOR SB SEVEN TWO ONE SENATOR
WEST SO THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE FLOOR COOLEY.
COOLEY I. GIPSON GIPSON HI.
TWENTY ONE. IF YOU- YEAH RIGHT
NOW. WILL BE GOOD TO GO.
FILE
ITEM THREE SB THREE NINE I HAVE
A TWENTY ONE.
OR.
MAKING A FOOL.
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS FOR THIS
ASSEMBLY GOVERNMENTAL COMMITTEE
IS NOW COMPLETE. WE ARE JOURNAL.